i'm going to use a business as an
example i mean we could use women you're
dating if you're spending plates we
could use business opportunities
um the reason why i want to start with
business is because i kind of went
through this exercise with a guy in my
business forum
last week because he's um
like many entrepreneurs a very scattered
brain it's like
i've got this option that option this
option that option it's like you know
everything's a squirrel or a shiny ball
it's like oh look a squirrel over there
and you get distracted sort of thing um
so if you have a little bit of 80d
then getting a good solid visual on an
easy way to kind of like rip through it
makes way better sense
um if you're watching this a few i got
to keep going through all these
announcements if you're watching this
on my entrepreneurs and cars channel
uh please take note you're gonna have to
come over to the unplugged alpha youtube
channel subscribe there if you want to
watch the full show
because i am going to terminate the feed
on entrepreneurs and cars on youtube so
make sure you get those links that are
pinned on the feed and in the
description
and it is what it is
i'm just trying to make sure that i'm
not i'm not dealing with guys going hey
you know what happened to your uh
your podcast i can't find it so i'm
simulcasting and trying to get you guys
over there to make it simple
uh there should be tons of time for q a
tonight because this won't take me very
long to rip through so
yeah get your get your questions ready
and uh we'll do lots of it open to
anything open a young old man woman
whatever it is you want even if you got
something you want to challenge me on
that i've talked about because you think
you got a better solution
let's do it let's do it all right so let
me throw up uh my
uh most excellent where is it do i have
it here still yeah i got an excel
spreadsheet
uh which will
reveal all
for you today um
okay come on cooperate
oh i see what the problem is it's got to
be open over here
there we go
there we go stream here it's a funky
little device
uh so let's go throw this up here like
this
and what's better this i guess you can
see this way too so let's do like this
um
so in the live chat right now give me
some
um businesses give me some business
ideas and we'll just kind of like do
this live together so let's uh
let's let's be creative here let's let's
do something funny let's throw in only
fans just for shits and giggles right
i'm gonna be an only fans manager and
run a bunch of chicks
uh give me some business ideas in the uh
the chat maybe ideas that you have maybe
a business that you run a business
you're contemplating running a business
family runs
uh just give me something there
uh welding all right let's do welding
we'll throw welding in for chris
holding biz uh car detailing
all right
give me a physical product too like
let's kind of like you know diversify it
because welding is a service card card
detailing disservice
only fans i don't know let's call this
service um give me a physical product
give me a physical product
something like uh
i don't know a widget
let's say a barbecue widget some kind of
some kind of accessory that you use with
a barbecue some sort of scraper or glove
it's called the barbecue glove
right
silicone barbecue glove or some [ __ ]
like that
um
what else we got here awnings real
estate
uh real estate i mean let's let's do
something okay let's do windows and
doors or something like that or
windows window installs
actually i'm gonna do funny one pressure
washing because this is one that guys
for some whatever reason i think is a
great idea and i'm not a big fan of it
so let's so let's just throw it in there
so pressure washing is what we'll use
all right so we've got a couple of
businesses here now
i've got to clean this up a little bit
delete
and so on the top over here we're going
to assign a score
of one to ten
uh with 10 being a highly elf business l
stands for easy lucrative and fun the
opposite side of the scale would be a
one which would be hard annoying lame
and frustrating i get into all the
details on this in my course i'm not
going to explain it today in this video
this is about making decisions but you
have to
identify what matters to you
like for example if you're doing some
sort of a matrix grid like this because
you're splitting spinning five plates
and you've been dating for a while and
maybe you're the kind of guy that wants
to have kids and you're vetting them
from other stock you could almost do the
exact same thing
but for this example we're going to use
business opportunities let's say
you know bob is contemplating and only
fans a welding business car detailing a
barbecue silicone glove uh and a
pressure washing business
for his entrepreneurial journeys because
he realizes he doesn't want to work for
the man he wants to do his own thing
okay
on the right hand side over here uh
these are the elf biz qualities
uh let me delete this box to pull it
shifts shells up i am not good with
excel so bear with me so on this side
over here we're gonna
use the
the descriptive terms so an elf business
quality would employ um subscription
income having low to no employees being
location independent meaning you can run
it from anywhere in the world
has low regulations uh that would uh
cause problems for the business let's
just say
it's an information or a service
business ideally information first
service business would be the second
choice
um so these would make it highly elf low
startup capital meaning you don't need
to borrow a [ __ ] ton of money to start
the business it's got good profit
margins so it's a profitable business
something that throws off a good amount
of money and it's easy to market right
because there's certain things that are
difficult to market and there's certain
things that are much easier market
i was at a retreat many many years ago
and one of the most successful
information products that had ever been
sold was done by this guy
that had an information product i think
it was called six pack shortcuts or
something like that six-pack abs
shortcuts or something like that
and
when he was doing a sort of talk on it
one of the things he said is like you
know look if you want an easy business
to market then you have to go
get paid get laid get six-pack abs
basically
get paid how to make serious money uh
get laid obviously how to get the girls
and get six pack abs look awesome naked
basically those things are really easy
to market people is what he said so
you know just to sort of give you some
ideas of some of the business qualities
that you might want to consider and
let's start assigning some scores to
these okay so just follow me through on
this this is not going to take long
we've got one two three four five
businesses we've got a couple of uh
measuring points here that we're gonna
try to figure out uh where they're at so
only fans uh does it have no employees
no because you're gonna have to have uh
women doing your uh chat they're gonna
have to be on camera they're gonna have
to promote themselves you're gonna have
to manage them uh i would imagine that
the women in this space are not
particularly easy to manage
um you know we've heard
guys in the space that sell this sort of
stuff uh mention that you have to get
these girls fall in love with you and
you're sleeping with them all and blah
blah all that sort of stuff so you're
dealing with a uh
interesting business of course with some
perks yeah
but i wouldn't call it um elf on that
scale over there because you have
employees that are going to be difficult
so
i don't know let's assign a three of
that just for shits and giggles uh is it
subscription income
yes because um the guys that are gonna
be paying for the services simps are
usually subscribing to it and they're
paying monthly and it's a fee
um i'm sure there's other bonus perks or
like tips you can give and stuff like
that but it i would imagine it's it's
primarily subscription income
um because once they form a relationship
where they feel like they have a
relationship they're probably going to
stick with it over a certain period of
time i don't know that you're going to
have a
three or four year subscription income
off it but i would imagine a few months
is probably common so let's go yes i
wouldn't say it's a 10 because you're
not going to have them for 36 months
it's unlikely but you probably have them
for at least three or four months so
let's give it like a six or something
right location independent can you run
it from anywhere in the world yes 100
are there low regulations
i'm not aware of any regulations
whatsoever for this sort of stuff um
you're not putting anybody's health at
risk it's not a nutraceutical you're not
making promises of losing weight or
gaining muscle you're just simply
entertaining simps so yes it's got low
regulations
is it an info service business uh yes
it's an information product a
subscription service business yeah so
let's give it a 10 there low startup
capital
um what do you need a decent camera some
lighting
um you need an instagram account you
need some thoughts that are going to put
out the content that you can obviously
uh manage
uh
yeah there's some startup capitalists
required but i wouldn't say it's that
high let's throw a let's throw a six in
there for giggles margin should be
pretty high for something like this you
probably have other upsells or other cam
services you can offer i would imagine
let's call it um
a solid six to a seven let's call it a
seven just for [ __ ]
because we've got too many sixes now
right easy to market yeah because it's
uh it's a kind of product that's easy to
market it's the oldest business in the
world right so let's call we'll
we'll throw it uh we'll throw an eight
or a nine there just for just for fun
all right so
we've now assigned a score to only fans
let's tally that up and we get a 61.
all right
so let's go to welding uh you need
employees yes unless you're employing
robots which is not um
you know that feasible for startup at
all for being honest so it's an employee
business so let's throw a one over there
because you're gonna need people
subscription income
um i would imagine some jobs might need
you to come back over time but generally
speaking once you weld something
together um if you're doing it on site
or
i guess it's generally on site because
they're not going to bring heavy metal
[ __ ] to you
so no it's it's generally not going to
be subscription income although you
might have some recurring maintenance or
recurring jobs that need touch-up work
location independent no you're going to
be locked to a demographic you can't run
this business from anywhere in the world
you're going to have to be a known local
guy
if you're a welder in toronto your
yellow pages is probably going to be a
plus welding toronto right so you're
dependent on the location so that's
going to tie you down i don't like that
for an health business low regulations i
would imagine there's workplace safety
you're going to need safety equipment
you're going to need insurance if
somebody gets hurt you're going to have
legal issues you're going to have
employee issues so it's going to be a
regulated business we'll throw a 2 there
it's a service business so let's give it
a 5 because you're providing a service
you're not moving a physical product in
the mail
low startup capital
i'm gonna probably go with no although
chris is in the
chat he can correct me if i'm wrong but
we say shop and field rich we build the
building and the stairs of the shop and
then install yeah okay so that's not
recurring revenue because that's done
done by the job so you're always hunting
for new jobs basically although you will
have builders that will have like i have
80 homes i need you to do a staircase
and you know sort of thing that you have
to do the install so you'll have income
over a longer period of time so let's so
let's fix that let's let's bump it up to
a four let's say
uh low startup capital no you need a lot
of equipment you're gonna need a diesel
truck uh to move [ __ ] around you're
gonna need uh
gas uh what are those cylinders
obviously i'm not in the business but
you know what i'm talking about you know
those massive cylinders that hold all
the different uh gases and stuff like
that that you need for welding so
there's a lot of equipment that's going
to be required the cost of it all i
don't know how expensive it is but i'm
imagining it's not cheap let's throw a
seven in there sorry let's throw a
four in there because it's not
uh low cost it's high cost
margins i think margins are high in
welding if i'm not mistaken
um
yeah chris is saying you're always
chasing jobs that's right and easy to
market
look as long as they're building [ __ ]
it's easy to market uh the trades are
almost always in demand they're always
building stuff if the um
you know if there's people moving to the
country there's high immigration even if
the birth rate's not high but if there's
strong immigration which there is in
most western countries it should be easy
to market so we'll give that a seven
so let's tally that up and we have a
31.
sorry chris you'd be better off running
and only fans
all right let's do car detailing this is
something that i'm familiar with because
i've done this before in the past when i
was a teenager i ran a car detail in
business when i was 16.
uh do you need employees not really but
you're you're going to be doing doing
the work yourself there's some employee
requirements so let's give it a tour
let's give it a two or sorry let's give
it a high score because you because you
uh don't need that many employees let's
get to seven
there's a
subscription um
look people need their cars detailed on
a regular basis because weather makes
them dirty and nasty
so once you have a customer and they're
happy with the work i mean the guy that
i use i bring my cars to him every
probably 60 to 90 days depending on how
much driving i've been doing
uh so yeah you do have recurring revenue
and you have a relationship with a
customer they keep coming back i know
they offer plans sometimes but they'll
come every month or something so let's
give it a seven for subscription revenue
uh location independent
uh yes you could run a car detailing
business
probably in the caribbean but why would
you if you've ever been down to the
caribbean the cars are dirty as [ __ ] the
roads suck you're not going to detail
there so there's limitations but i mean
you can detail a car
wherever you are i suppose within reason
we'll give it a five
low regulations yeah there's not many
regulations required um maybe some
insurance required if you're running a
legit business it's not cash
but regulations are fairly low let's
give it a seven
is it a service business yeah let's give
it uh
an eight it's right up there low startup
capital it's reasonably low i would say
um
you know water some cleaning chemicals a
pressure washer doesn't cost much uh
margins are pretty decent your cost of
materials to detail a car
probably less than 15 to 20 bucks if
we're being honest with water and
cleaning chemicals and if you're
charging 400 bucks for a detail
uh you've got decent margin that it's
just you know you're going to be tired
of the m for being honest it's you know
it's an exhaustive business you need a
lot of energy for it so
margins are high we'll give it an eight
easy to market
yeah if you have a nice car and it's in
a uh
affluent neighborhood it's pretty easy
to get customers to spend money like you
know anywhere from 400 600 bucks to do
some detailing where people spend a lot
more i've seen people spend you know a
couple grand for full detail where they
take off wheels and they clean the
undercarriage there's a photo shoot
involved and they do
sealers and all this kind of stuff um so
if you're in affluent market and you're
targeting that it's reasonably easy you
know i would say you get customers
pretty easily so let's call it a seven
um
boom
and again you know these are all
uh subjective to you know your inputs
and what you know about it so let's do
it like a barbecue silicone glove that
you're going to sell on
amazon or something like that maybe
you're going to have to promote it
through facebook ads or you're going to
use
the ad platform native to
the fulfillment house
do you need employees not really it's
actually a
pretty
low employee account that you're gonna
need for something like this
subscription income no because if
they're gonna buy your glove they're
probably gonna have it for quite a long
time so you don't have recurring revenue
off it you're like one sku stew right
location independent yes you can run
this from pretty much anywhere in the
world low regulations
it's a glove it has nothing to do with
uh promises of uh losing weight removing
wrinkles from underneath your eyes or
anything like that it's not it's not a
consumable it's not a nutraceutical so
yeah it's got very low regulations uh is
it an info or service business no it's a
physical product physical products you
have to source from the supplier they
sometimes take a while to get to you
fulfillment houses make uh create
problems sometimes with shipping
shipping companies sometimes deliver and
it gets stolen
they may get it and they don't like it
and they have to return it depending on
the product because this is a barbecue
silicone glove it's not going to break
in the mail so it's anti-fragile but if
you were shipping something that was
fragile that could break in the post
you're going to have problems with it
right so
you know
with something like that i'd probably
give it like a two you know let's say
just because it's because it's a
anti-fragile project that won't break
but still you're gonna have returns
you're gonna have lost products you're
gonna have problem sourcing you're gonna
have added costs associated to your
supplier if fuel prices go up for
example so there's all kinds of issues
that you run into with a physical
product that you don't get with a
digital product or a service based
product again this is all stuff that i
cover in my course guys so if you're
interested in learning more about the
school of entrepreneurship and
everything that i've learned over the
years make sure you're on the email list
for when it launches next monday and
you'll get notified there
low startup capital uh barbecue glove no
because you're going to need to have
some money to buy your inventory of
gloves the more you buy
if you order 10 000 units you're going
to pay less than 500 units for a
thousand units or 100 units so just keep
that in mind there's some startup
capital it's going to be required is it
a ton
probably not as much as a welding
company
but it's still going to be up there i'm
going to give this a 5.
margins probably pretty high because if
you're buying some cheap [ __ ] silicone
glove from china for
a couple bucks and you're selling it for
20 or 30 you've got a good marketing
campaign margins can be pretty strong so
i will give that a big fat eight
easy to market
i'm gonna say reasonably but it's gonna
come with some costs
um
actually speaking of costs let's take
the margins out of the equation and give
it a six or seven because you're gonna
have to spend
uh quite a bit of money on advertising
on facebook instagram even native to the
uh fulfillment house platform whatever's
you know that you're gonna use you're
gonna have to advertise it straight up
uh is it easy to mark yet i'd say
reasonably um
yeah people like buying trinkets and
[ __ ] i mean there's no question about
that i don't think it's as easy to
market as something like an only fans uh
so we'll give it a
six or a seven i'm just gonna give it a
six just for shits and giggles all right
let's do a service based business called
pressure washing right now
you have employees uh you you're gonna
need a couple of employees probably but
it's not gonna be a huge employee
account but we're gonna give that a
[ __ ] four let's say
um subscription income
um you know if you have a customer on
your books you might have annual jobs
that you do um i think most of the
pressure washing places that i've talked
to
um that have asked me questions or have
come to me for consults generally
have contracts i mean if it's commercial
you're gonna have commercial contracts
so every certain period of time you're
gonna go back to do the work you might
have a spring gig or a fall gig so
there's some degree of subscription
income that comes off this although it's
not monthly
for the most part unless you have a
commercial contract location independent
can you run it from anywhere in the
world no you're going to be locked to a
demographic so your you know your listen
is going to be a plus
pressure washing toronto
for you to set that up in
miami or la is going to be
an entire process so i'm going to give
it a low score for location independence
because even though you can move it
around it's not a location independent
business it's not like you can take all
your [ __ ]
and start selling your barbecue silicone
gloves from a beach in
your uh boxers while drinking a corona
uh you know your feet up in a hammock
like you could with the one prior
regulations for pressure washing you're
gonna need some insurance um there's
probably a few small regulations but
it's gonna be a very low regulation
business it's not like um something like
you're dealing with financial services
or nutraceuticals or making promises to
lower weight or anything like that
is it a service business yes we can give
that a high score
low startup capital i'm going to go with
yes because what do you need um you
wouldn't probably need a diesel truck to
tow that [ __ ] around
you could use a van or a gas truck um
you just need a gas pressure washer and
some hoses and maybe some chemicals so
it's not that high of a start of capital
cost
high margins
um
not as high as some of the opportunities
that are out there but yeah you know
there's money to be made at it easy to
market
if [ __ ] gets dirty and you live in a
climate where it's dusty it's rainy
there's seasons it should be reasonably
easy to market to your customer base so
yeah um wouldn't be that hard to market
for being honest
let's add those up
all right well you've just evaluated
five different businesses with clear
scores across the bottom over here
and based on the elf model that i talk
about in my school of entrepreneurship
the kinds of business that are ideal to
run versus ones that are going to be
more difficult to run
we have only fans
car detailing
and what's number three barbecue
silicone glove
right
so
it's pretty easy i mean if you were
a guy that was considering getting into
the welding business or in only fans
it's it's a pretty clear winner that if
you want an easy lucrative business to
run only fans would probably beat
welding all day long plus you're dealing
with hot women but that's going to come
with a bunch of other sets of problems
that anybody that's dealt with hot women
in the past that are problematic are
going to obviously be very very familiar
with yeah
so again like you know you can use this
for a whole bunch of other stuff hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you